thank you
[Music]
here's a pretty uh genius thing a guy
did and uh he made the government look
pretty stupid because of it
but they were doing a buyback for guns
and uh
uh exploited the state's buyback program
he was printing them he was 3D printing
oh smart smart I heard about those [ __ ]
that's smart dude yeah so he made all
these gun parts uh he said he printed a
bunch of lower receivers and frames for
different kinds of firearms and then he
drove six hours to Utica to the gun
buyback event and
um told them that he had 110. different
guns to sell back and they came back to
him with 42 gift cards counted them in
front of him and he made twenty one
thousand dollars
we gotta get a 3D printer yeah because
the buyback is like 500 per or something
right 500 per yeah the best thing is
that the guy's doing the BuyBacks don't
even know what guns are so like oh yeah
that looks like a gun to me holy [ __ ]
sound oh yeah I'm getting this thing off
the street it would be different too
yeah yeah
and so he did it with like a 300 3D
printer that he bought yeah
here's the funny part about it so the
state is like uh condemning him to like
say oh it's so shameful that this
individual exploited a program that was
successfully used to take thousands of
guns off the streets [ __ ] he said what
the [ __ ] he goes what I did demonstrated
how much of a joke this is exactly oh
yeah yeah downstairs how much a [ __ ]
dumbass you are yeah and he said this
does nothing to take guns up the streets
at all bro just like everything
government does do you guys hear Newsom
is doing some [ __ ] about parking where
he's like oh yeah they wanted like a
bunch of new parking locations like
downtown I just denied them
like basically saying like [ __ ] you dude
so part of the new future is like we
shouldn't have places to park more
places to park to distribute last
because it discourages people from using
like vehicles that aren't TVs so there's
less parking spaces yeah but that's part
of their 10-year plan Bray we're not
supposed to even have like [ __ ] cars
that use gas by 2032 or some [ __ ] so
that's part of the [ __ ] like I can't
get past it it's just so like these
people are so dumb I don't know how
anyone votes for them even once
don't even let them make the mistakes
just don't vote you don't know I don't
practical use of just having less
parking spaces no he's like oh it's good
for the environment yeah is it bro like
meanwhile we need more coal because we
have to like subsidize all this EV [ __ ]
because the EV shit's not making up for
the ROM that they have with needing to
to have electricity yeah it doesn't
sustain itself exactly it not yet we're
called to make more batteries damn right
there's enough batteries to make more
batteries so the pollution is just more
localized to a place beyond your line of
sight yeah exactly if you're in L.A
already where it's pollution what's more
pollution so that's what they do it's
not outside of your site it just takes
you 40 more minutes to find parking so
you're just using more gas and Battery
don't even go to the event that's
supposed to be helping the ecosystem
anyways you don't go to the rally for
change yeah well that's buddies because
they're basing this like cause and
effect projection on a thing that has
never that way like when you make things
less convenient you don't get that
desired result no dude that's not how it
works but anyway I made a mistake about
this article the um 3D print was
actually two hundred dollars oh oh wow
for Christmas so it was free
all profit dude yeah
they always have to factor in if you got
it for Christmas
I wonder if that makes it less criminal
like where he can't be prosecutive like
the lawyers all we don't have a cases
what the [ __ ] were we thinking yeah are
we sure we got it for Christmas oh yeah
we know Christmas gifts go up yeah damn
it boss like how do we know we gotta for
Christmas I'm so sorry we have home
video and he's like God damn
I love that uh VHS that after he pulled
this [ __ ] scam successfully on the
state the state was like we will ensure
that no one can exploit this program
like that again let's hear it it's like
why you don't get to talk like that
after falling for something [ __ ] dumb
yes it's crazy they don't cry reference
[ __ ] like you know if they have like a
program where they're like okay I know
if we want to get these illegal guns off
the streets we'll have a program where
you could bring in these illegal guns
and then we'll buy them off of you like
that's an interesting model why don't we
test it with another illegal thing oh
how about if you bring in illegal drugs
we'll buy it off of you and then they're
like no I don't think that's gonna work
because I think drug dealers will just
sell directly to the government you know
what I mean like just take a model and
actually like yeah that's and then go
wait that's a stupid model because now
we're just paying criminals to bring
[ __ ] in exactly it's like what the [ __ ]
they don't even think like the next
layer over yeah it's crazy I'm kind of
down for us as a group to find an
exploit and exploit it the [ __ ]
potholes right the pothole Mafia bro
[ __ ] tripping foreign
that's what I do dude but like this kind
of shit's different like yeah I could
find something that's giving me like six
six six six sick returns like give me
like [ __ ] 350 or more but dude not
this [ __ ] with the government [ __ ]
that you're gonna get wrecked
they're getting wrecked more than I even
imagined getting right from crypto
we got pretty rest pretty rough but if
you were smart
and you weren't Anthony Lee and you
weren't like Mr five your plan Mr best
light plan
I think you did pretty well
there's way too much meta in that one so
I don't think they got it is there
anything that like
in your mind can you think of anything
close that would possibly disarm
criminals in a willful way no way
magnets
where would you say
whoa yeah super strong magnets
so it's going to take a gun from
someone's hands
if they're under your shirt they just go
whoa
where am I being led to what if you go
like this you go magnet and it just
sucks all the bullets out at you holy
[ __ ]
through the magnets to your heart
hopefully you held it in front of you
yeah
oh
you're lucky what about a new initiative
turn in your weapons and clear your
record
okay it's like the Fresh Start program
or something a dancer would fall for and
then they start all over again
can you just [ __ ] be on my TV I love
you what if it's like clear clear your
record and you're allowed one sex
offense per year oh [ __ ] I think a lot
of people go for that I think Andy's
like
more incentive don't do this because oh
no incentive incentives are good yeah
yeah oh no but Andy's like uh walking
like an Egypt
[Music]
there's got to be something like what do
criminals want that you know the [ __ ]
will get them to stop being criminals
come on one of you guys knows it so you
wanna only get rid of the illegal guns
right
how do we get that from the people that
break the law right this is what scares
me about bart so he already has the
answer no I died yeah you have a lot of
cop friends I'm just thinking this is
what scares me about Ryan he already has
the answers he's waiting for everybody
to be a dumbass no I don't have it the
article has no more info that's it
that's really tough come on I mean
because if they're trying if they're
resorting to things like BuyBacks and
like when's the last time a buyback
worked in America do you think they're
just doing that just to save face though
yeah because they have to be doing
something because they got it they're
being funded you really probably don't
think that it's good they're being
funded to do stuff that's it it's a
[ __ ] kafka-esque cycle part of
misdirection they even tried this thing
in California where they're like oh you
know what since we're gonna label uh ARS
like assault rifles or whatever if you
register in time they will pardon anyone
that does whatever and then everyone
that I know that I know in the gun
Community probably 90 no one registered
them you know why because they know ARS
are armor light not [ __ ] assault
rifles they're like the word like why
would I register that's so weird no
Steve they're all assault sorry bud I'm
sorry I didn't realize I was walking
like an Egyptian right now
accepted I gotta admit it's it's getting
more creative out of desperation
sorry the Bengals
are you Mike Mike's song yep yeah yes my
boy Max Hall
I'm pretty convinced that there's
nothing really that you can do to
convince criminals you can't have it
especially like he's got to get more
guns and if you want to turn it to a gun
list state in general I think it's
probably gonna be equivalent to get
having people give up their cars
you know what I mean it's gonna be like
like that kind of the Band-Aid that no
there's more guns it's gonna be like
that it's like it's like almost as if
people that rely on their cars whatever
it's like hey you're gonna have to give
up all your cars I think it's just as
hard as having everyone give up at least
when you so this guy who has eight cars
that's true exactly we get our pay cut
no at least at least when you drown a
car it doesn't work anymore you draw a
gun it probably works after it does yeah
so give me a [ __ ] break what we
should do for the next JK Adventure that
we do we should go you guys should come
with us and with me and Anthony and
we'll buy guns for our first guns oh
wait wait I want to buy mine too okay
that's actually my process we all buy
our first gun my third gun you know
what's gonna happen and then we go to
the shooting range no dude you know it's
gonna suck for you guys because since
you guys are in California you can't
pick it up for [ __ ] 10 days so then
we'll do a before and after in the first
nine days I gotta shoot someone
and the roster is absolute [ __ ] oh would
you like if you want the [ __ ] Best
Buy because you really need a laptop and
you're like well guess what you'll pick
it up in three weeks that sounds like
regular Best Buy now Bart have you been
yeah no it's like anything online when I
got my HP Envy dude this piece of [ __ ]
then guess what I had to do this I had
to do the same thing really yeah because
there's no inventory anymore because you
know the [ __ ] economy is just so
killer supply chain you know you might
not have noticed it but Steve just
indirectly backed me up already no I
didn't you just cut it cut that
foreign
[Music]